the Justice Department is expected to
charge two more former NFL players in an
alleged multimillion-dollar scheme to
defraud the league's
health program ten former players have
already been indicted for them played
for the Washington Redskins including
running back Clinton Portis Nikole
Killion is outside a FedEx field in
Landover Maryland the home of the
Redskins Nicole what have we learned
about this investigation
well Michelle some of these X players
have been arrested while others are
turning themselves in that includes
Clinton Portis who spent much of his
career with the Washington Redskins and
is well known in this community today he
is expected to surrender to authorities
but his attorney insists he did nothing
wrong it's a play that the Justice
Department is now blowing the whistle on
this is very much like a typical health
care fraud scheme federal prosecutors
indicted ten former NFL players
including all-pro running back Clinton
Portis on fraud charges and accused them
of using a leak healthcare plan like a
personal money machine by de frauding
the plan and treating it like their own
personal atm
sadly the defendants placed the plans
tax-exempt status at risk the players
were charged with nearly four million
dollars worth of fraudulent claims for
high-cost medical equipment they never
actually bought the claims typically
ranged from forty to fifty thousand
dollars apiece for a hyperbaric oxygen
chamber used by scuba divers ultrasound
machines and electromagnetic therapy
devices used on horses you would be
surprised as the casual fan or observer
some of them were unconventional or
seemingly unconventional avenues that
these guys take to get their body home
Doug Eldridge who represents a number of
NFL athletes says these actions if
proven could make it harder for other
players the veracity is now any question
then they will seek to poke holes into
every fourth klemming claim
poor toises attorney told CBS News in a
statement his client is quote completely
taken aback by the indictment and will
move forward with the process of
clearing his good name and those of his
fellow NFL alumni the NFL Players
Association declined to comment the
charges these former players faced carry
penalties that could put them behind
bars for decades if convicted Tony all
right Nicole thank you very much
interesting case ya know it's not always
you can assume that these guys made some
money while they were playing but you
often make it young you don't always
save it and you could face difficulties
in your 30s on the other hand it's out
alleged that this is fraud but meanwhile
they're lawyers saying hey these guys
have unusual ways of staying healthy
remember they were in the NFL right a
lot of them have injuries yeah yeah it's
gonna be harder now for other people
making those claims yeah very
interesting case Nicole thank you very
much